if you've watched me for any amount of
time at all on my channel
I talk about race a lot I talk about the
bigotry and the hate that it exists
within the Republican party I talk about
the Republican Party being the largest
and most organized white supremacy
organization on the globe
and one elements of that is several
members of Congress who are vowed
Christian nationalists and along when
you hear the term Christian nationalists
you should just automatically understand
that it is white Christian nationalists
there was no black Christian nationalist
that's not a thing it is a an
exclusively white byproduct of racism
and fear
of their flavor of Christianity and
Marjorie Taylor green is one of these
people
a vowed Christian nationalist who speaks
at is invited to speak at and accepts
the invitation of Nick Fuentes to speak
at White Christian nationalist
conferences
and she now on committees
they're having a conversation in this
committee about the actions that led to
the death of Tyree Nichols in Memphis
Tennessee
and she talks
how terrible it was
and then inexplicably
expectedly but inexplicably pivots to
yeah that's really bad and all but
there's a lady in the audience whose
daughter was killed by police
that woman
her daughter's name was Ashley Babbitt
and then goes on to to have sympathy and
and draw attention to a woman who tried
to who was a q Anon adherent who tried
to overthrow the United States
government by force by overturning a
free and fair election who almost made
it onto the house floor to commit who
knows what Mayhem
watch this moment despicable moment for
Marjorie Taylor Green in committee
just the other day
oh and it was tragic and and extremely
difficult to watch I would also like to
point out that that city is Democrat
controlled and the five officers that
have been arrested and charged are black
and I think that this isn't isn't an
issue of uh racism or anything like that
I think I think that the judge and the
the jury and the trial needs to work out
what happened there but I share that
with you but I'd like to also point
something that I'd hope you share with
me there's a woman in this room whose
daughter was murdered on January 6
Ashley Babbitt
and Ashley Babbitt has there's never
been a trial as a matter of fact no one
has cared about the person that shot and
killed her and and no one in this
Congress has really addressed that issue
January 6 committee didn't address it
and I believe that there are many people
uh that came into the capitol on January
6 whose civil rights and Liberties are
being violated heavily and this
committee will I I hope uh Mr chairman
look into those civil rights abuses uh
because they're happening in a jail
right here in this city and I hope Miss
Norton uh will will care about that as
well
gross disgusting reprehensible
yeah Tyree that's sad and all yeah but
you know it's not racism because those
cops were black
you know the real Injustice is that
Ashley Babbitt was murdered she says she
categorizes a woman who stormed the
United States capital with a mob
amidst them were people with shirts that
said Camp Auschwitz on them
parading through the capitol with
Confederate flags
a hangman's Gallow constructed not
hastily constructed planned and executed
built on the lawn of the United States
capital but a thousand feet from where
they were chanting hang Mike Pence they
they came with an objective
to overturn a free and fair election to
disenfranchise you and millions of other
Americans if you voted for Joe Biden
because they wanted their dear leader
back in office a violent attempt at
overthrowing our government
she wasn't murdered
and those they are securing conviction
after conviction after conviction of
these individuals who did indeed attempt
to overthrow the United States
government
for the power for the for the party of
of of of Law and Order and back in the
blue and blue lives matter until
it butts up against their ideology and
their base
Tyree Nichols wasn't a domestic
terrorist
Tyree Nichols
the the accusation from the police that
that ended up killing him was that he
recklessly drove
which has been rebutted by the chief of
police herself
in Mississippi or excuse me in Memphis
she says there's no evidence of that
so what we know is really there was no
crime committed
by Tyree Nichols there's no comparison
to be drawn between Ashley Babbitt the Q
Anon clown and Tyree Nichols
but leave it to Marjorie Taylor green
leave it to the chaos caucus leave it to
the Republican party to put her on a
committee
to create a spectacle and a circus
and a distraction
from what really needs to be
accomplished in our country that is
where we are so thanks a lot Kevin
McCarthy
bang-up job you're doing a Speaker of
the House of Representatives making
cover for insurrectionists an
insurrection apologists
like Marjorie Taylor green